we don't have the right to subordinate
other people to our ends or treat them
as objects through our uses and that is
a fundamental kind of equality hi my
name is Zack Weiss molar for a reason TV
we're here at Liberto PIA 2012 in San
Diego I'm here with Roderick long
professor of philosophy at Auburn
University and president of the Molinari
Institute
Roderick thank you very much for joining
us your topic here at Liberto Pia is
race gender and anarchy why should those
interested in reducing the size and
scope of government be interested in
discussing ideas like race and gender so
on the one hand you have libertarians
for whom the you know the defining
principle of whether something counts as
a rights violation is whether it counts
as a physical invasion of your person or
your just acquired property or the
threat thereof something like that on
the other hand you have people on the
Left who are concerned with systems of
oppression based on race or gender or
class or various other things that don't
seem to count as rights violations in
you know by libertarian standards and so
as a result these two groups tend to be
somewhat hostile to each other but I
think that both sides are mistaken you
can perfectly happily embrace a robust
understanding of the non-aggression
principle and not soften it or weaken it
or or anything like that and the still
at the same time think that the left
definitely onto something when they talk
about these forms of oppression that are
not directly forms of rights violations
let's say you know there's an employer
who clearly discriminates against some
sort of group whether it's women or a
certain race or people with disabilities
right now we have laws to combat that
that would be the use of force
what's a non aggressive way to fight
back against that sort of discrimination
in many ways the elbow of the state has
laws against discrimination the state
indirectly does things that tend to to
make you know either to incentivize
discrimination or at least make it
easier so many traditional
aryans will argue that there can't
really be that much genuine
discrimination in them in the market
because the market would you know would
tend to penalize people who hire on the
basis of something other than who
systematically hire in the basis of
something other than competence if women
operate at the same productivity and you
could pay them less money more people
would hire them because it's better for
the bottom line that's the argument it's
the argument they make and you're saying
it's incorrect well here's what I think
was wrong with that is that first of all
we're not in a free market and when you
have these larger and more hierarchical
firms which are I think in many ways
less efficient but are able to be to
survive because they able to socialize
the cost of government privilege one of
these that happens is that the people
making these decisions these firms have
a hard time determining what the
productive contribution of a particular
employee is you've got a whole bunch of
people working together and then you've
got some employer Ohio you know high up
who serve distance from what's going on
in the floor anyway and they have to
make their decisions and there isn't
that much price feedback so the
decisions are gonna be based on their
judgments and their judgments might very
well be influenced and that no not
necessarily by hostility to women though
there are certainly is such a thing but
by you know if they if they come in with
sort of a presupposition than women are
less productive than men well that won't
get corrected and even if it's wrong and
so they're more likely to make decisions
on that basis and so you'll see that
kind of thing go on so that's just an
example so you're saying it's the
regulatory state that has created these
giant firms that may engage in bad
practices and that is one of the sources
now I'm not saying that there can't be
you know that there can't be sort of
systematic bad things happening in a
free market too so what do we do about
those various kinds of private
associations consciousness-raising
groups unions which is a scary word for
a lot of libertarians but you know what
I'm talking about unions with government
privileges we're talking about
associations of workers you know joined
together and demanding certain
conditions as part of their bargaining
and so forth there are you know
non-coercive ways of achieving these
things and if libertarianism is right
then those are going to be
more effective and you know one size
fits all top-down bureaucratically
imposed coercive solutions when we're
talking about you know race gender
sexuality any of these kind of
categories a discussion arise is also
about political correctness and you've
written about political correctness it's
a term that tends to scare a lot of
libertarians but you say that maybe not
all political correctness is a threat to
free speech and maybe there's a need for
it political correctness refers to a you
know a whole bunch of different stuff
and as is often the case with terms that
refer to whole bunch of different stuff
some of its good and some of its bad so
when people talk about political
correctness they often worry about
certain kinds of very intolerant thought
control and and so forth and you know
that that exists and that is practiced
under the form of political correctness
and I think it's harmful but many of the
things that get dismissed as mere
political correctness I think are you
know sensible attempts at you know at
civility and at recognition of genuine
new harms and inequities that people
have faced libertarians often say well
why should we pay any attention to you
know feminists for example because you
know the feminists most feminists are
not libertarian they're anti libertarian
they want all kinds of government stuff
so why should we care about them of
course then the feminists can say why
don't you care what libertarians Austin
R anti-feminist right which i think is
an equally fair point there was a time
in the 19th century when you got you
didn't get this divide as much 19th
century libertarians particularly many
of the United century American
individualist anarchists saw the state
and racial oppression and gender and
class and all these things are sort of
interlocking systems of oppression they
were much more nuanced to all these
things many of them anyway were but I
think that on the end of the 19th
beginning the 20th century sort of
libertarians and left went their
separate ways
and libertarians are specialized in
understanding you know how markets work
and how government intervention works
and the left has spent more time
specializing in understanding how how
sort of non governmental forms of
oppression work and on how sort of non
market forms of voluntary Association
work
and each one came with some very
valuable insights and in the stuff that
they were working on but tended to lose
track of the other stuff right if you
bring the two sides together you and
bring the main insights that just sets
together you can really have a much more
powerful social theory another idea
that's typically associated with the
left is equality you talk about
something called equality of authority
we're all equal Authority that means I
don't have the right to impose anything
on you without your consent
you don't have the right to impose
anything of me without my consent we
don't have the right to subordinate
other people to our ends or treat them
as objects for our uses and that is a
fundamental kind of equality that
anything is at the root of
libertarianism that libertarianism is a
profoundly egalitarian doctrine in that
sense believe it with that thanks very
much for talking with us
Roderick long a reason TV I'm Zack